maybe the best place to start would be
let's explain what job well is and then
we can kind of go back in time and get
to where we are now cool cool so also
thanks for coming in absolutely my
pleasure thank you for having me
appreciate it yeah so Joppa was a career
advancement platform built specifically
for black Latinas and Native American
students and professionals and we
basically allow companies to diversify
their applicant funnels before they hire
the best people for the job
we got really frustrated when companies
would say you know we can't find this
talent it doesn't exist and for us me
being a part of the community it was
writing like BS it definitely exists I'm
here yeah and and there are 44 million
black Latino Hispanic and Native
American students and professionals in
the workforce that that that exists as
well and so we wanted to create a
platform so companies can no longer say
oh this is like a pipeline issue we
can't find this talent yeah exists and
their own job well and what made this
problem obvious to you when you are at
Goldman so it starts actually before
Goldman and actually goes back to kind
of where where I'm from and kind of how
I grew up it's doing so my dad's from
the Bronx originally and he was the
first person in his family to go to
college and work in corporate America he
became a general counsel for a publicly
traded utility company and so I grew up
in the type of household where to be
successful and I put air quotes around
that you have to be a doctor you have to
be a lawyer you can go into finance and
that's it and I felt this large
responsibility to kind of move the
family forward as my dad did and I was
kind of like this thing that I grew up
in this you know middle-class family
where that was like a responsibility
that my sister and I both felt yeah and
so when I was in high school Morgan
Stanley was offering a diversity
internship program somebody tapped me on
the shoulder and said hey this is like
that finance industry you should pay
attention to it and I got lucky I
applied it got the internship and I
started working there my junior senior
summers in high school went on to
college went to Yale played basketball
there and it's
playing basketball in the summers I
continued in a really early access
pipeline focused around diversity
recruiting and I spent three summers
interning at Goldman Sachs and I started
my career there I was there for three
years buying and selling currencies and
so while my background was getting early
access you know really starting when I
was about 15 or 16 years old and I found
my way into buying and selling
currencies yeah I recognize how unusual
my path was how fortunate my path was
and it struck me that you know despite
despite me finding my way to my seat I
knew that a lot of other people weren't
finding their way to a similar seat and
I had kind of looked around and and
realized that it wasn't just a finance
challenge when it comes to recruitment
people of color is really all industries
and at that time the summer of 2014
right before I left all the tech
companies came out with these stats of
like the lack of diversity which is
something we all knew right but it was
the first time it became really a
national conversation and so my
co-founder and I decided that we can we
can make a solution for this we can
build a platform of people of color yeah
and we can leverage technology to
directly connect them with opportunities
that historically we haven't been
exposed to and create that authentic
connection between the employers and
potential employees and so that that was
really how we started it we wanted to
make impact and as a result of that
impact we also wanted to be able to
build a profitable successful business
on top of it so we set out from the
start to build it as a for-profit entity
and not a non-profit which there are
many amazing nonprofits that that focus
on diversity recruitment uh-huh but we
just took their approach to leverage
technology do it at scale and solve a
problem you know going back to the whole
YC mantra where you guys engineers like
you know so you're you're trading
currency what gives you the idea that
like you're gonna build this recruiting
pie come
I again to this day still probably the
least technical person at job well I was
a political science major in college
zero zero tech bums in my body but but I
lived through this I I'm passionate
about diversity recruiting I'm very
intimately interwoven within all of the
stuff that kind of goes on within
recruiting and so I from experience knew
that this was like a major problem and I
knew that technology can can help solve
it mm-hmm
and even though I didn't know I wasn't
thinking through the code of what that
would look like
I had a platform in mind of what it
could be so what how did you test it out
in the beginning or did you wait until
you had something built before you
started yeah so basically what ended up
happening for me is that after my second
year at Goldman my cousin passed away
and for me when that happened it was
kind of like the first I've had plenty
of people that I've known that have
passed in different settings whether
it's my parents friends or neighbors or
whatever the case may be but this was
the first time that somebody that I
would consider not only family but close
friend passed and given that he wasn't
much older than me
it dawned on me that you can die at any
time and it was a and it was a it was it
was a true awakening for me to really
figure out what the hell I want to do
with my life and so after my second year
I decided that I'm gonna go on this
journey to figure out what do I want to
do and I felt that it given that I had
an opportunity to play basketball at
Yale and had this amazing network at
Goldman Sachs I had a responsibility to
leverage that for impact yeah and I
didn't know what that impact was gonna
come in the form of or the shape of but
when I kind of took a step back and
after a year of kind of going through
this thought exercise around challenges
I see in the world what I'm passionate
about what my experiences have been it
all kind of tied to diversity recruiting
and providing opportunities for others
through leveraging my personal networks
and so I told my parents at the time
that I'm gonna quit and build this
company and they said okay
get this straight your non-technical
you've never built a business you've
never done recruiting and that's going
to be the company you start yeah that's
exactly what I'm going to do it right
and you're saying this to fairly
conservative parents who are like you
have three options yeah they did not
they were not feeling it you're like
you're you're you're literally going to
die if you try to do that and and that
was a really frightening thing to have
my parents say that to me you know it's
a really awkward thing if you really
look up to your parents and you respect
them and and and and you view them as
like your role models it's really not a
natural thing to kind of go against what
they're telling you is a really bad idea
but but in terms of you know testing
this out I'd never really tested it out
because I live through it I was so
convicted with it and I and I like
intimately understood what the pain
points were mm-hmm so you know ignorant
is some degree and so I had this vision
of like of course this is going to work
on I don't really have to test it and I
was so focused on doing my job really
well when I was at Goldman that I didn't
I didn't have the time to try to build a
business on the side I wanted to give a
hundred and ten percent to what I was
doing and when the time was right to
leave than to give 110% to that and so
you know it wasn't probably a wise thing
to do
but definitely took a leap of faith and
said this has to work why wouldn't it
work yeah I mean just being in a large
company even I mean now it's more
obvious but even a few years ago it was
obvious that these companies really care
and people like yourself want those jobs
so like why not match them together so
did you start with a demand like did you
start with one partnership how did that
work so going back to me being
non-technical it actually really helped
because when you're building this
two-sided thing and I did and I didn't
come to find this out that this was a
challenge until probably when we're
going through funding for our seed round
during demo day that like you have to
pick a side first at the time there was
no choice because we couldn't build a
platform for users because I couldn't
build anything so all I could do is make
a pitch deck because that's what I was
really good at being an analyst at
goldman sachs yeah so i just set out to
me
Dec and I made this deck along with Ryan
my co-founder and we just showed it to
companies and said this is what we're
going to build and if we build this will
you be a customer and so we got really
fortunate that when we made these phone
calls people answered they took our
meetings they took the deck seriously
and they said sure if you build this
like we'll definitely be a customer
because what you're trying to solve for
is a real pain point of ours and we took
a couple of very flimsy yeses eyes yes
we have customers yeah and then from
that we were able to raise a little bit
of money hire some people who built the
platform got the other side okay and did
you wait can you yeah there's a who I
see in the timeline of this show the
July 3rd 2014 was my last day at Goldman
Sachs all right
September is called September 1st was
when we kind of set out to make this
pitch deck to show to companies let's
say by the end of September we had about
three or four soft yes sure when you
build that let us know man we'll be a
customer but for us that was like okay
they're they're gonna be a customer and
we had them sign this one-page letter of
intent that says if you build it we'll
partner with you and then once we had
that by October we decided okay we have
customers we need a platform we have to
raise money and we need to hire people
who can build it and so we got very
fortunate that people invested in Ryan
and me and we were able to raise
$500,000 with family friends networks
within a course of about a month and a
half
Wow yeah and and it was like shocking to
us it's something that we didn't foresee
happening we thought I was gonna take a
year but what ended up happening is that
going back to you know like the networks
that we were able to build people invest
it in Ryan and me mm-hmm
and and it was great to kind of go back
to places and tell them what we were
doing with people that have known us in
the past and they were so supportive and
then it started kind of as we all know
when you don't need capital you start to
get the capital so once we started
getting our first few checks it it was
downhill from there
and then so now in November so we hired
our we hired our first engineer person I
went to high school with and so now we
had a team of three and we also hired
another individual who I went to high
school and so we had a team of four with
one engineer without a one engineer over
a three three non-technical one engineer
alright guys and now this isn't call it
november/december yeah so side note we
were you in any way experienced vetting
engineers zero okay so you're saying
they seem nice slim buyers of my high
school fiftieth reunion for their first
black student and there's this amazing
gathering okay and and we were kind of
you know networking with one another
yeah and Randy Brown was standing next
to me a person that was a couple years
younger than me in high school okay
Randy how's it going like what do you
what are you up to he's like well just
graduated college and I'm still working
on my thesis I was a computer science
major in college and so I'm kind of
playing out my thesis full-time now but
it's not really going that well and just
trying to figure out what I want to do
and well we just raised a little bit of
money we're looking for a engineer
so Randy became our first engineer and
so you know and I think that's the story
of a lot of people where you just hire
your closest friends and yeah that's
pretty common in common and so that's
that was our story and it also ties into
our first four people were
african-american and and the reason why
I even bring that up is because you have
a lot of small companies that their
first four employees are white males and
it grows from there yeah and so in our
DNA we started out as an incredibly
diverse actually not diverse because we
were all the same similar backgrounds
and and ethnicities and so we have to
grow out of that and yet to be you have
to be really intentional about growing
out of that yeah but as you hire your
friends and your friends friends and
that's how companies scale so when we
think about like the difficulties of how
companies come to get to where they are
where there's a lack of diversity we
experience it from a very extreme other
side of things but it's the same thing
right
it's just like higher friend go from
there and then yeah could you have to be
intentional about it you have to be
aware of it yeah and so so then you
apply to I see for the winter back no so
we we then we then actually applied it
to New York tech stars okay and did not
get in was in December May date made it
to the final round they basically said I
don't understand diversity recruiting is
not a big challenge and and and and you
guys don't have anything like I don't
know why you think this this would be a
good idea
and so really okay alright well
appreciate the feedback we then launched
the platform in January users came onto
the platform rather seamlessly and it
was kind of like a no-brainer why
wouldn't you sign up we had those
companies that said that they were be
there they were there they were they
were actual employers started getting a
lot of traction a lot of users a lot
more companies and it kicked off really
quickly and then so around March or so
apply to YC for the summer session
gotcha and got it and so so yeah good
thing they did against in the rest of
sister so a good thing that you know you
have these setbacks and and you get so
excited about like these accelerator
programs and and it becomes this
distraction and it was so fortunate that
we didn't get in and it was so
devastating at the time but then six
months later four million dollars later
were in YC yeah so you're still here so
live there company exists yeah yeah so
just so I understand from the from the
supply side yeah these people these
underrepresented employees in tech and
finance it's all across industries right
yeah they're still applying to these
companies right so why are they looking
for a platform like job well at first to
just apply on LinkedIn or what
absolutely so the way that we'd like to
think about it is that many many people
when they are applying for roles or
opportunities you generally know
somebody okay there's some attraction to
that organization there's some
connection to that company and and for
people of color
it's if you look at the numbers in tech
for instance right if two percent of
your workforce is black and three
percent are Latino or Hispanic odds are
you don't know anybody that works there
right and odds are you're not gonna have
that champion that kind of says hey guys
this is I'm looking out for this person
make sure you screen this candidate and
so what we want to do and what we want
to be is the referral at scale for our
community so job will partners with
these organizations we want to be your
foot in the door and that entity that
becomes your referral if you will and so
when when users aren't Javal or saying
you know why don't I just apply you can
and you should but you're gonna go into
a black box and unless you know somebody
and when you apply on job well really
what that means is that you're applying
to companies that truly value diversity
as that they're partnering and paying
job well to have access to this
community and when you apply through our
technology we can flag candidates to
companies and so we can ensure that they
have a more diversified pipeline now we
can't ensure you want to get a job we we
can't we don't know the candidates on
our platform on that one-to-one level we
have we have we are fortunate that we
have a large community anyone to sign up
if I can sign up but we're very direct
and who the platform is built for is
Bill for black Latino Hispanic Native
Americans and so that's what the
community has grown to be just that
and so when candidates when candidates
are applying and when we let the
companies that work with job will know
hey you know you had a thousand people
apply for this one role or you had 30
people apply for this one role now they
can ensure that they have a more
diversified pipeline because they have
jockle candidates in their funnel along
with other candidates okay and now we
can at least make sure that before they
hire the best person for the job that
they have a diverse applicant pool and
and that's where we come in so yeah a
couple questions so we had one question
from Twitter
about the pipeline in particular where
are people coming from they're just
signing up for job well yeah so we
you know we've been incredibly fortunate
that the community has really accepted
what we're trying to achieve we
fundamentally believe and and truly
understand that we can't be successful
unless we have the support of the
community yeah
we're a product of the community we're
building this for the community and so
they've grown our community and it's
largely been through word-of-mouth job
will be incredibly involved with various
activations and clubs and organizations
and informing really strategic
partnerships and and really being the
the solution at scale that a lot of
smaller organizations haven't been able
to really focus on they focus on a lot
of you know coaching training mentoring
which is so important and for us we just
took a different approach that we wanted
to do it at scale and leverage
technology to connect people to
opportunities but formalize
relationships with all these amazing
organizations that are doing such
amazing work right and to figure out a
way to both help them and for them to
help us and and so a large part of our
growth on the community side of the
platform has been a result of the
community yeah you know really
leveraging job well and regionally you
said their East Coast West Coast for the
most part the major metropolitan areas
is really where we do the best we we
tend to focus most of our employers to
be within like major metropolitan areas
huh a lot of our user base comes from
those those similar surrounding areas
gotcha
and and so we you know we stay kind of
focused in that and then on the the
second part of the question from Twitter
was about are there certain roles that
maybe differ from the average in terms
of job well candidates getting and doing
well in our do you have that yeah I
would say all across the board the
candidates do really well in terms of
the types of roles whether it's in
finance or attack or consulting or
sports and but what I would say is that
what we do really well in is call it
people within their 20 or 30 something's
within their age range and so really
that entry-level to mid-level talent is
where we thrive the most we do have
people with that we would consider
executives on the platform but it's
less of a sweet spot for what we do
mm-hmm so if you are typically you know
in college or call it sub 12 years or so
in the workforce that's kind of where we
operate the most okay got you and so in
terms of the industry as a whole you
guys are I mean obviously this diversity
conversation super important and only
more talked about in the past couple
years since you guys have been around
and you ten years what have you noticed
in terms of changes in the industry and
where do you see it going yeah I'm here
so the first thing is whatever
frustration but but when I hear the word
diversity and I hear people describe
diversity challenges I think that one
when I hear that I don't really hear
much because that diversity is kind of
it could be yeah it could be anything
you can make an argument that anybody is
diverse and that really that really I
think inhibits companies from actually
moving the needle when it comes to what
their actual challenges are so if you're
looking at across corporate America and
the reason why JA polis is built for
black Latino Hispanic and Native
Americans it's because it's the most
underrepresented groups within corporate
America and so companies that have a
really difficult time connecting with
this audience they should just say that
and not just say we have a diversity
challenge they they need to be able to
truly identify what diversity challenge
like what vertical of diversity or are
you kind of focusing on and then you can
find solutions for that particular thing
and so I think the companies that are
the most intentional and are willing to
have the most uncomfortable
conversations are the ones that do the
best and they need to be able to clearly
clearly articulate to an entire their
organization about why diversity or a
particular subset of people within the
diversity or umbrella is so important to
that organization it's been proven time
and time again now through multiple
studies McKinsey is has come out with a
couple of studies BCG around having a
more diverse workforce leads to bottom
line
and it just makes sense and if you're
trying to build a world-class
organization and you're trying to invent
products that are going to change the
world how can you do that without people
at the table who have differing
backgrounds and experiences and opinions
and by the nature of being a person of
color I'm going to experience the world
differently right then maybe my white
peer and so even using me as an example
where yes I had a fabulous opportunity
to go to Yale I'm so fortunate for that
but at the end of the day I'm a black
male in this country and when I'm
outside and I'm engaging with people I
don't have the Yale tattoos slapped on
my forehead people first identify and as
I first identify as a black male and
they're and so therefore I am seeing the
world through a different lens I'm
experiencing the world through a
different lens even if I had a white a
white counterpart that also went to Yale
yeah we're still gonna experience the
world in a different lens so when I come
to the table and I'm giving you my
experiences in my background and my my
opinions just being a person of color in
America I'm gonna have a different
thought then what you might come to the
table with and that's important and that
leads to innovation and so it's so
important that companies have a mixture
of people from different backgrounds
ethnicity sexual orientations you name
it you need that that you need that that
that tension that those conversations to
occur because that's where innovation
happens yeah so I agree with you but the
what I'm trying to figure out is you say
okay diversity saying broad like we want
a diverse workplace like to you is just
like noise for the most part but you
want to be specific right so how do you
be specific and inclusive of those
people without being by default
exclusive of other people yeah
absolutely so I think that's that's
something that a lot of companies feel
that they again it's going back to like
that uncomfortable conversation yeah
yeah totally because people are scared
right there like a little [ __ ] like I
didn't want to offend that person by
trying to include this person whatever
absolutely I think so long as companies
frame it yeah within the organization
itself as we're doing this because it
makes business sense and stick to like
this leads to bottom line success
for this company if we diversify and we
really start to attract candidates from
different backgrounds that we haven't
recruited from in the past we need that
in order to stay relevant the
demographics of America is shifting by
2040 the people of color in this country
are gonna be the majority for the first
time so if you can't if you can't build
for the future you're gonna get past and
it's such a business imperative
conversation that if you keep it at the
business level yeah I think it becomes
less of an awkward conversation and less
unless so of all we can't we can't bring
this group of people in we can only
focus on this it's like no we're trying
to be the best organization possible
yeah we don't have a lot of
representation we need more
representation from these groups within
America we don't look like what the
broader American society looks like in
what its shifting to be yeah so we need
to double down and triple down on those
efforts and I think that if you can have
that conversation and keep it at the
business level then it becomes less
uncomfortable I guess the question that
I'm asking is like on the positioning
side so like outwardly facing how do you
best deal with that to attract the most
like the most different kinds of
candidates to make your company better
so you know like work with job all right
obviously that's the obvious thing but
out but I think the more important thing
is recognizing that you're struggling in
a particular area yeah and as a result
you should ask for help and I don't care
if it's through da Pole or somebody else
but I feel that a lot of tech companies
want to build a way out of it or they
want to solve it themselves okay so yeah
what and so and so I think that a lot of
organizations again going back to kind
of he'll drop will start at hiring a
couple of friends and how many
organization starts where you hire a
couple of friends you have to get
outside of your comfort zone you have to
find different pipelines
to attract different types of talent and
you need to be vocal about that and
publicly facing about that because
companies like JA Pole and other
organizations will come to the call and
so and by being so out there and being
so public about
you're what you're lacking in you more
authentically present yourself in a
favorable light to a community of people
that you're calling out to try to
attract and you're saying we're looking
for you we need you because we're trying
to out-innovate our competitors yeah and
so I think raising your hand and just
saying publicly like we need assistance
with a particular challenge is the way
that you kind of get out your own way
and you start to unlock other pipelines
of talent right and so does just
Facebook Simon not Facebook but like
tech in general the the breakdown of you
know these these types of employees does
that match the computer science
enrollment in terms of percentages or is
there a drop-off like what I'm wondering
is about if we're gonna increase the
number overall does it start when people
are seven years old and you get them
into CS or how does that work so so so
what also that kind of frustrates me
about about when we hear the the reasons
as to why they can't find this telling
it all goes back to why we started job
low yeah
with people saying oh we can't find this
talent yeah and and when companies say
oh you know there's not even like the
pipeline of black blue team of spanic a
Native American engineers one that's not
true and the data does not suggest that
at all and and what is laughable is that
let's say that is even the case yeah
okay let's just say that is even the
case which it's not but let's just
concede that and say okay sure
sure what about everything else what
about every other non-technical
non-trivial yeah within your company if
your company is two percent black or
three percent you know a Spanish or a
Latino you can't say that you can't find
enough people who are people of color in
non technical roles sales consulting
finance HR you name it and so if your
organization is still not a
representation of what America is
broadly you can't point to the pipeline
thing that just doesn't it doesn't hold
up do you do
you just kind of not have that
conversation with companies what we're
really fortunate about and again from
like a business perspective I
fundamentally believe that if you're
making two pitches to a company you're
making two different cells yeah hey this
concept is a really good concept and you
should use us too for this particular
yeah that's a lot of that's a lot of
convincing in a conversation we're
incredibly fortunate now that we can
call it we're fortunate but we are very
strategic about the companies we work
with because we're only making one cell
we don't choose companies to work with
that don't believe in the value of
diversity sure so the only cell we make
is why you should use drop well okay so
we never get into the conversations
around why diversity is important to
your organization because they
understand it they've reached out to us
we're very transparent I'm very vocal
about what drop will stands for so as a
company if you're reaching out to work
with job well we shouldn't have to
educate you on the value that a diverse
workforce can bring and so we just
talked about why you should be
leveraging job well in our technology
and how we can diversify your applicant
funnels okay we that's it let's talk
about that actually because there there
are there are a bunch of companies that
have gone through YC or just are
interested in listen to the podcast or
whatever that are doing recruiting right
so zooming out a little bit from chapo
specific focus what is your advice for
running a recruiting platform for
entrepreneurs I would say that if you're
trying to build a hiring platform you
have to be known for something okay you
have to have a particular you know focus
you can't just have claimed to have
quality talent you have to have you have
to be providing a real solution to a
real problem that companies face
you should probably associate with that
problem you should probably have
experienced that in some capacity or
have empathy as to why that challenge
exists you should be very passionate
about whatever group of individuals
you're trying to serve
to unlock that opportunity and and you
should be doing it because it's making
impact not because you think it's a
company I can make a lot of money yeah
and if you can kind of stick to those
things and you can build something that
becomes sticky and everything else
happens as a result of that then great
happy days for everybody but to start
the company you really have to isolate a
particular challenge in pain point that
employers face and just work on that one
thing okay and and can you talk about
that specifically in the context of your
product like what are some things that
you guys have worked on that have been
meaningful increases in like you know
whether it's people getting jobs or
onboarding new companies or whatever so
going back to kind of like my story how
when I was when I was gone growing up
and you know again like as as my parents
told me with air quotes now you know you
got to be you got to go into finance if
you're gonna be successful you have to
be a doctor or a lawyer there are a lot
of people of color particularly in
America where you grow up thinking I can
only work for these particular
industries or these particular companies
and so you go through life thinking
that's really all I'm qualified for and
what we've been able to do is through
technology which has been so awesome to
be able to do this is that when you
create a profile and you give us all
this information that's proprietary to
javo from yes your background and you
know your work experience but more
importantly what your interests are yeah
what types of working environment do you
want to work in where do you want to
live and work within the country what
words describe yourself right a
leadership moment write a personal bio
about yourself
what are your dream companies like when
we collect all of that information and
we can take an account what you've done
and what you're currently doing now we
can expose you to opportunities that you
didn't even realize you were qualified
for mm-hm and so we are showing
candidates
that you know what you were pre-med in
college do you know how incredibly
qualified you are to work in tech or to
work in finance or to work in a variety
of different other industries yeah or
that political science major like I was
but I was very operational and my
mindset which enabled me to kind of you
know build a tech company mmm how
qualified I am to work in particular
industries and so what we're now able to
do is expose our community to
opportunities that historically they
haven't been exposed to and really start
to truly diversify industries that
didn't know how to connect with this
audience yeah and so but we've only been
able to do that through a product in
leveraging technology mm-hmm and do you
is it common for these people on job
well to be getting their first job here
or do you have people coming back to job
well they like trade up or switch out or
whatever that's worth three-and-a-half
years old and we're just starting to see
candidates that got their first job and
now they're getting their second job one
job well and that's been awesome to kind
of go through for the first time but
again like our sweet spot is typically
that entreats mid-level so sometimes
it's candidates looking for like their
third job their first job and everything
in between so oh yeah because I'm just
curious because you mentioned showing
people the path and I totally agree I
think that's like basically how every
person goes through life and they're
like oh you know a friend of a friend
started a tech company so I know them
I'm a smartest em I can do a tech
company but if you don't have that it's
really difficult so yeah I mean you what
you're talking about this is your sweet
spot will that evolve over time or do
you think this is the area that'll
always absolutely so going back to kind
like the YC mantra of like doing things
that don't scale yeah when we first
started we were very campus focused it
was just university and then by you know
the brand of JA poll just being in the
world yeah people just started signing
up from all different you know ain't age
ranges and so we kind of took a step
back and examine the community and we
decided okay JA pol needs to be more
than just internships it needs to be
professional opportunities as well but
as a result we should speak to you very
differently yeah depending on the stage
of your career
so what we've now done with our platform
is that based on certain tags and
triggers and whatnot we speak to you in
a different tone so people when they
interact with job well yeah they're they
have different personas that job well
that they're interacting with not
everybody has the same experience on the
platform and the more experienced you
are the more personalized it feels and
and that's a really important thing for
us mmm-hmm
it's kind of a random question but uh I
I know certain people that are fairly
vocal and for example like women in tech
but then sometimes they're just like I
want to just talk about product do you
ever feel that way
um I do I have a responsibility yeah to
speak about being a black founder yep
you know it's it it really is painful to
see the lack of black funding that
occurs and it's again when when VC said
oh well there just aren't black founders
that is so it's like scratching on a
chalkboard it's and it's so frustrating
yeah
and so I feel like I do have a
responsibility to speak a lot about
diversity speak a lot about the funding
paths that drop will went down speak
about my experiences going through Y
Combinator yeah I recognize that with
this position of being the CEO of the
company that is part of the that's part
of the role yeah and so yes I would love
to just speak about product and what
we're working on but our entire ethos as
a business is to unlock opportunity if
I'm not talking about those things that
that can help others become
entrepreneurial entrepreneurs and hear
my story about my parents telling me I'm
crazy but still kind of taking that leap
then I'm not I'm not living up to what
I'm supposed to be doing as a CEO of
this particular company right well it's
also just I mean it's kind of like part
of you so you can't not talk about it
it's impossible not to did you find
again again it's like you so it's hard
to compare and contrast an experience
raising money as a black founder do you
find it to be different it is very
different
and and it can feel very intimidating
okay until what ended up happening for
me is that during one of our pitches
with a really prominent very prominent
VC the the conversation started with a
lot of a lot of associates and a lot of
partners around this table following Y
Combinator and the question to basically
start the meeting before ever going
through the first slide was I don't
think this is a good idea this is not
this is not a publicly traded company
and and when you start out the
conversation like that yeah without even
going through slide one something
happens in you and for me that something
happened was where I fully recognized
for the not for the first time am I've
always had the confidence in whatever
and I'm being an athlete and having
athletic mindset but it was really the
first time where I kind of came back and
was like you know to be honest like
don't know what you're talking about
like I'm from this community I know the
pain points I know what the opportunity
is I know how much money our community
spends in this country I know how much
of a challenge it is for these
organizations to hire people of color
that I'm the expert in this and you're
not and so - all of a sudden flip the
conversation on let me teach you
something and I'm the teacher and you're
the student now that gave me all the
leverage in the conversation and once a
senior partner at a firm feels like he's
being taught in a very respectful way
the leverage changes right so in other
words like having deep knowledge of some
things use use a confidence to enter any
room and have a compass tab solutely so
now after that experience yeah and it
turned out that that we had a fabulous
conversation following that and they are
in an investor in Joppa land there
and a VC that we work closely with but
after that experience every time I enter
a room its I'm gonna explain to you and
share with you why this is amazing
opportunity and by the way we don't need
your money and that's always like a very
powerful position to be right so so yes
being a black founder and going into a
room where there's literally nobody that
looks like you is a very intimidating
thing until you flip it on its head and
you recognize that you're coming with a
very unique experience and and and an
opportunity that they have never thought
through so it's so rare to be the expert
in that room but you are the expert in
that room when you're talking about a
challenge that's uniquely that you've
faced would you buy the same learnings
to going through YC or were there
different yeah so I think what the most
powerful thing for me going through IC
has been is that we know so intimately
well what we're trying to do and our
vision our vision is so locked in on
what we're trying to achieve yeah but
I'm a first time entrepreneur I'm a
first time CEO and no matter what it is
you're trying to solve there are certain
things that like YC can just tell you
you're gonna step in the [ __ ] in this
area and yep you should think about that
thing that's going to happen six months
from now and all like these things these
war stories that you get access to yeah
they all happen and so combining the
knowledge of YC for like what's about to
happen and what you need to think
through combined with having a really
set vision has made all the difference
in the world and now being you know
twelve million dollars in the funding
and being a series a company and having
35 employees what I'm most excited about
for YC is this new initiative where I
think it's if you get to 50 employees or
something you can kind of come back to
YC as as as a real alum to speak to
other alums that are now going from 50
to 100 and what's that process like and
so that's that's just ahead of us and
I'm excited to kind of you know jump
into that now right on broadly speaking
what were your learnings and lessons
from YC because we are like the majority
of people listening to this or maybe
thinking about starting a company or in
the process
could you condense what you learned
absolutely so the number one thing that
I took out of YC because it has a lot of
implications is that funding is an
outcome of building a good business and
it sounds so simple and and and I didn't
fully appreciate it when when when when
when everybody was kind of preaching
that when we were there like guys stop
focusing on demo day does it make
traction and everything else will kind
of you know happen it's again it sounds
so simple but when people ask me like
okay like how do I go and get VC funding
I'm like we'll build a good business and
and by having that concept of just
building a good business it truly
eliminates so many distractions yeah and
it helps prioritize your day yeah
where you're just focusing on making a
good business and focusing on your
customers and building something that
they want yeah that when you lift your
head after a year VCS are calling you
and the process isn't difficult to raise
money at that point because you're just
talking about your business and your
traction hmm and that was the number one
thing because you know as I mentioned
like without a company or a product we
applied to techstars we had no business
applying to anything we should have just
built a good business and by the time we
apply to YC we had built a business that
was getting traction in ten weeks later
we raised three and a half million
dollars on demo day and it was just
because we built a good business and you
know that's something that uh you read a
lot of blogs and you follow all these
famous VCS and you're like oh I would
love to raise their capital and you're
so focused on the wrong stuff it's
unbelievably distracting and I think
people get in their heads that like
that's what winning the game is and they
also lose sight of the fact that these
investors have LPS in other words they
have their own investors so all this
like content marketing that they're
doing has an interest yeah and their
interest is like you are in this VC game
and so I think it's great if you want to
do a start-up and raise VC but a lot of
people are like
like basically taught that that's the
only way to build a business and that's
also not to fill the business so yeah
yeah and then it's like you realize wait
a minute why my line dilute my dilute
myself why don't I just make money from
customers and not have to raise money
great too and so yeah that's you can
just do it your own way
yeah I don't have you don't really don't
have to it and and if you could build us
and what I tell people is that if you
can build a small business like try to
try to build a small business first
worry about the big business down the
road but just just try to make a hundred
thousand dollars with your company like
try to make five hundred thousand
dollars with your company and then and
then see what happens but people get so
caught up and out and I was I was in it
you get so caught up on raising capital
and trying to get to certain milestones
of ARR and all this stuff just like go
out and make a hundred thousand dollars
yeah it's not easy it's so simple and
it's such a weird thing because going
through YC what I take out most of YC is
not about the demo day and the funding
it's about building a good business yeah
and it's so something you wouldn't you
know associate you you would think that
like from the outside it's like raise as
much capital as you can and that's just
not what gets preached at YC it's just
build a good business and that's by far
would I take the most out of the program
and what have you learned since have you
made any I don't know any mistakes or
any counterintuitive learnings even a
couple years now focusing on the culture
it's the number one thing that like you
know when you're when you're four people
it don't really have to focus on it just
it's just you know is what it is and
when you're ten people you really don't
have to focus on it yeah at some point
when you're fifteen when you're twenty
you as a CEO that's your job and it's
your job to make sure that the vision is
is clear everybody can talk about what
that vision is everybody understands
what their KPIs are what their should be
focused on you're the captain of this
boat and there's land out there and you
have to tell people which island you're
going to and you have to be very set on
that path but be flexible enough to
adjust meanwhile you have to keep the
crew happy
and it's a balancing act innocent
juggling act is something that I was
really good with until we were 12 people
I was always a captain of my basketball
team I was always a captain of my
baseball teams and all that stuff so
managing and coaching and leading
anything sub of 1213 people came
naturally once we hit the 15 number I
started losing my own way because I was
friends with people but I was their boss
you know like I wanted to like hang out
with them but I had to like give him
critical feedback and it was really when
we had 15 people that I would say I had
the most difficult kind of like
reflection on on like who do I want to
be as a CEO and in being a CEO is like a
real thing and I thought like being a
CEO so it's all you you do sales and and
that's and that's kind of what you do
and you just have a cool title yeah but
it's not like you have being CEO is
keeping everything together and having a
clear vision and constantly driving that
home and so for me I would say 15 to 20
people was definitely my largest
learning experience where I had to
recognize that I'm not your friend first
I'm the CEO of Joppa first and I can be
a colleague second yeah and that or a
friend's second if you will and that
really helped me find my voice again
mm-hm and now 35 people I've it's around
structuring my day so I have like very
intentional about my schedule and my
calendar now like I'm you can't just
pull me into a meeting like you have to
give me an agenda what the meetings
gonna be on I have particular blocks of
time you can we can we can have meetings
and I just have to be really protective
over my time and so like that's like the
next phase of learning them going
through that like it's okay to give
yourself a four-hour block where you're
just thinking about the business and
you're not being pulled into me meetings
to be busy like if I don't need to be in
the meeting I shouldn't be in the
meeting I think that's a lesson for
everyone
yeah just is but yeah absolutely did you
have a coach or did you just read books
or blogs or what what did you do um a
little bit of everything
I don't know Debrett coach mostly books
a lot of just speaking with people yeah
and I would say just most of it getting
feedback from from people who work at
Jah quo and just being very intentional
now I have a coffee session where every
morning I get coffee with a different
employee for about 45 minutes because I
go get coffee anyway so I might as well
go with somebody just sit down and just
have a conversation and it's in those
one-on-one settings that I can get real
feedback and it's just listening and I
don't have a big enough ego to think
that I know everything again as I said
I'm not the most technical person in the
company I'm not the best product person
in the company I'm not the best marketer
in the cup I'm not the best of anything
in the company but I have a real clear
vision on what I want Chapel to be mmm
and and so I want to hire people who
have the expertise and I want to learn
from them and so it's a constant
learning it's constant feedback and it's
just being humble enough to recognize
that you like you know you got you got
to bring people into the fold to help
you through stuff yeah dude that's great
well I think we should wrap it up there
thanks for coming in absolutely my
pleasure thank you
you